- Been kind of hard lately.
I don't know, like, I'm super hopeful
about the future and
I'm embracing the grind.
But sometimes it's really,
like, tiring, but...
♪ Somebody asked me how I'm doing ♪
♪ And they meant it ♪
♪ I don't know how to answer ♪
♪ I don't know how to phrase it ♪
♪ And frankly, I don't know ♪
♪ How I still maintain all my friendship ♪
♪ 'Cause lately I've been in my head ♪
♪ and kind of left it selfless ♪
- My guess is that my friends are all
just better than me. And it's a blessing
how I find a girl who's better than me.
We fell in love way back
when I was someone better
than me. She's like a drug.
The high she gives me
even better than weed.
She's like a feather,
indeed. I love to carry her.
She's far from a burden but I know nothing
that's heavier than my
heart when it's hurting.
And all this music,
and all these endeavors
I've been working on
are just representation
of things that I've been
learning from or running from.
'Cause honestly, I'm scared to death.
I dropped outta school,
my life is testing me.
I can't bear the stress.
I don't care for rest.
I got way too many things to get to.
But I realize I'm not defined
by all the things I've been through.
That's all you get.
Go listen to the record.
(Gael laughs)
- It'll be everywhere on the
screen and the description.
And it's gonna be the new
intro for the series. So...
- I hope y'all connect
to the record honestly
and find me on Instagram.
I think that's probably
one thing I look forward to
the most is connecting with
people who love my music.
- I guess I'll start off by saying,
"Would you like to have some tea with me?"
- Yeah! I would love to have some tea.
You got some tea for me?
- Here's mine. Let's do a cheers.
- Oh, I keep dropping this.
- That's not good.
- Yeah, I'mma hold it. I'm okay with that.
- You could clip it on.
Have you seen my most recent
episodes on my YouTube channel?
I hope you haven't.
- I have not.
- Okay, good. That's perfect.
I'm glad you haven't been watching them.
So this whole series is just called,
"Would you like to have some tea with me?"
And the whole point is to
just to get to know you.
I guess first I wanna know
how are you doing, really.
- I'm all right, you know.
I just moved to a new
town with my girlfriend.
So, that's exciting but, you
know, it's also stressful.
So, just dealing with that,
but I've been pretty grateful lately.
Some days up, some days down as usual.
- How long have you been
with your girlfriend for?
- It's gonna be five
years on October 30th.
- Oh, wow. Congrats.
- Thank you. Yeah, I'm
very happy about it.
- Can you tell me a little
about how you guys met?
- Yeah, so, we both went to Penn State
and we were both off-campus housing.
And I would see her on
the bus all the time.
And I lived somewhere that
was kind of far from campus.
So, nobody liked to go there.
So, you would only see on the
bus people that lived there.
So, I saw her a while,
my second year there
and I hadn't seen her before.
So, one day after a long study session,
she was on the bus alone and I was like,
"All right, this is my chance."
So I just approached her and
yeah, we started talking.
She kind of ghosted me
and then two weeks later
I pointed her out to my mom.
My mom came to visit and I
kind of showed her to my mom.
- Like, you guys were
all on the bus together?
- Like, two weeks later.
My mom came to visit and we
were about to board the bus,
and I kind of tell my mom,
kind of like, "Oh, this is who..."
I actually tell her in
French so I could be slick.
And she turns around
and points at the girl.
And she's like, "Oh, is it her?"
- Your mom?
- So, there was a whole awkward situation.
So, I texted her 'cause I had her number.
I texted her, "Sorry about that."
And then we kind of talked again,
and then we hung out the day after that.
And then five years
later we're here, yeah.
- Thanks to your mom.
- Yeah, straight up.
My mom takes credit for it for sure, yeah.
- What was her perspective,
like, on the whole thing?
Like, when she was
noticing you on the bus?
- She claims that she thought I was cute
and she noticed me. She claims.
- Okay, alright. That's
all you need to know.
- I mean that's five years later,
so I believe her, you know.
- Cool.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna go back to my
first question actually,
'cause I do want to share the story
of how you are doing, really.
- Yeah.
- So yesterday, me and
my cousin, we were just-
It was my only day off.
- Oh wow.
- Literally.
- When you came in at Pata, right?
- I came into Patagonia.
- Yeah, that was two days ago, right?
- That was two days ago, sorry.
This whole trip's been a blur.
- Yeah. Yeah, tell me about it.
- Two days ago we were shopping.
We walked into Patagonia.
My cousin found a jacket
and she wanted to get it
and I told her, "No, you'll
find something nicer."
- Okay.
- So that's why we didn't check out.
We didn't meet you the first time.
- Okay.
- We didn't check out, we left.
- I didn't see you guys leave
the first time, actually.
- You didn't see us at all?
I noticed you the first time.
You were just, like, at the cashier.
I noticed that you were the cashier.
- Yeah, I mean, probably
that's why you saw me
'cause I was the only one at the register.
- But you didn't notice me the first time?
- No, I think I only saw you
when you guys were walking towards me.
Or I think when you guys
came back the second time.
- Yeah.
- I saw you guys walk by.
I recognized you at
first but I wasn't sure.
Then on your way down to
checkout, I heard your voice.
And I was like, "Okay,
that's absolutely her."
- Everyone always says they
recognize me by my voice.
- I mean you have a very particular voice.
And I think, like, it's very recognizable.
Like, I saw you and it didn't click fully.
Yeah, when you spoke,
when I heard your voice,
my heart just dropped. I was like,
"Oh shit, it's definitely her."
Yeah. That's why I almost
didn't remember you.
Gosh, I was like, today I
said, "Nice to meet you."
And she's like, "You
met me the other day."
I was like, "I'm sorry."
Listen. I wasn't like-
I couldn't believe what
was happening 'cuz yeah.
We'll talk about this song in a second.
'Cuz whatever the reason
why I knew you was
is something super important to me,
like, in my personal life, so.
- To me, too. To me too, seriously.
- Yeah. So.
- But, let me.
- Yeah. Let's tell 'em.
- Sorry, I thought they
were talking to me.
- Oh, me too, honestly.
- But Shen, is this? You're good? Okay.
Are you heading out?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Okay. Gimme a hug before you go.
(muffled voice)
- Nice meeting you, homie. Be safe, bro.
- You as well.
- I have these binges I do,
where I go on YouTube to cry.
'Cause there's so many
amazing videos, like,
like I think that's how I
would land in on the channel.
'Cause I saw the, like the
question, and I was like,
"Oh, I gotta see how
people react to that."
It was the, "How you doing really?" video
where you were asking
strangers how they were doing
and just actually pushing
as opposed to settling
for the regular answer that we
all so used to giving people
and giving strangers. But yeah.
Favorite record. Yeah.
Created because of that video.
So, thank you. I guess.
- Thank you. Don't thank me.
It was the strangers.
And like, it's a combination
of just people inspiring each other.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah. That's why I want
to tell you the story
about my other friend,
because the record wouldn't have been...
Like, the inception was
because I was inspired
by your video, but you inspired me
and I wrote the first half.
- Yeah.
- Which inspired him.
- Right.
- And seeing him be
inspired, inspired me back.
- Right.
- To finish it.
- Yeah.
- Which is why it's even a record.
Which is why it was even
a conversation to have.
So, you know the full
circle, that's all that is.
I mean.
- Teamwork.
- I know, right. Unintentional teamwork.
And to think about how
much it meant to me before,
I can't even explain to you
how much it means to me now.
Like, even more, so.
- So yeah, the first line you say,
"Somebody asked me how I'm
doing and they meant it." Yeah.
- Yeah. And I think, I think, yeah,
I was just going through a lot and, yeah,
just, like, asked myself,
I guess, how I was doing
after I saw it.
And this song has been
my response to myself
and, like, struggling with the idea of,
like, being honest about how you doing
with yourself and with other people too.
'Cause I believe I've written
technically better raps,
but it's my favorite record,
like, by far, to this day.
Yeah. And I don't listen to my music much,
but I listen to that song.
- You listen to that one.
- Yeah, yeah. Quite a bit. Yeah.
- I do wanna tell you, like,
so you gave me the song, right?
In Patagonia. And this will be, like,
probably my top 10 favorite
memories of my life.
Me and Shen we went outside the Patagonia.
We were sitting on this thing,
and we were waiting for Uber
and we played it. And,
like, as soon as I heard it,
I swear to God, like,
just like the first intro.
Like, I was like, I like, this is so good.
This guy's so good.
- I don't believe that.
- And then what you did to, like,
what happened to me when
I listened to that song
is why I do what I do.
'Cause I want people to feel that.
You know what I'm saying?
And so like, yeah,
I ran back in there. I was like,
"I'm gonna message this guy
and I need to interview him."
- And also honestly, like,
it's rarely something so personal.
Like, I feel like people will look up
to an artist because they love his music.
But, when it's somebody
who specifically had, like,
an direct effect on your
life and I think it's, like,
that's why I was so, like,
you know, like, lost in
in the whole situation. It
was just like, I was like,
"You have to tell her."
Like, "She has to know."
'Cause I was like,
"Where else am I gonna
get to tell you this?"
And also I was like,
I know you're not based here too.
- Yeah.
- That was crazy.
- So, I was gonna ask you
what's a line in that song
that, like, hits you the most.
Like, that you're, I don't
know, that stands out to you?
- My friends are better
than me and it's a blessing
how I find a girl who's better than me.
We fell in love way back when
I was someone better than me.
Mentally, the spirit behind those bars,
I would revise them a
little bit because I think
I was not giving myself enough credit
'cause I was going through
a lot of shit at that time.
And I really didn't love myself.
So, there was, really, no love there.
It was full on judgment and
trying to figure out how I felt
about myself, like, how
I could live with myself
or how I could prove to myself
that I could get better.
I think I should've
given myself more credit.
I don't think I was, I don't
think I fell in love with her
when I was better than me writing that.
I don't think I was a better person then.
Which I think she also helped me see.
Even talked about my parents.
Saying that I won't stop
until I got some gold
in my neck and I pull my folks outta debt.
And around my neck right
now, that's not real gold.
So, I feel like I've been
super blessed with my family.
And I think there's a, somewhat unhealthy,
feeling I have of, like, being a burden.
Not too much, but I can
be a lot to deal with,
especially for my parents and stuff.
So, I don't know. I just
kind of wanna flip the script
and just, like, let all
their problems become mine,
and none of my problems, like, be theirs.
Like, so yeah. I think that's,
everything I just said,
that's what this record means to me now.
- Let me look at my list of questions.
I have a bunch of questions for you.
What's something I
wouldn't believe about you?
- I have a lot of social anxiety.
And I don't know if that
sounds like pretentious
or anything. But I have coworkers at work
that couldn't believe it
because I seem so social
and good with people and stuff.
But, yeah, most of the time I
don't want to leave the house.
I don't leave the house
unless it's necessary.
Or if it's something that
like means a lot to me.
Like, it requires effort for
me to be around people a lot.
Like, for example today,
it was, it was still hard,
like, getting out.
Not because I will be anxious
socially around you guys
or you, but the train, just,
just being around people,
I, like, I get paranoid on the train.
But I can't remember not being like this.
I can't remember what it's like
to not have social anxiety at all.
Like, I can't remember
what I was like before.
Yeah. It's yeah. It's, I
mean, a lot of what I do
is to maneuver around it.
So, my whole, the way I carry myself,
the way I am, just, in
life is largely dependent
on, like, where my anxiety is.
So, it's become like a
huge part of my life.
Like, you know. I would
change that if I could.
Yeah. And I'm actively working on it.
Some days are better
than others, you know?
- What's your biggest insecurity?
- My biggest insecurity is
that I'm not as good a
person as I wanna be.
- Why do you think you feel that way?
- Like, I'm not gonna get into
the details, but the thing,
whatever my girlfriend and I went through,
I didn't do anything evil or
inherently bad, like mean or,
or like I was a bad person to her.
The worst part of my life
in terms of how I behaved
or the part of my life that I look at
with the most pain
happened so unexpectedly
and happened from, came from inside of me.
So I'm sometimes on the
lookout, I'm scared.
Like something else is coming
that I'm maybe even more like
damaged or dealing with more
stuff than I think I am.
So it makes me scared
that I really don't know
what I'm capable of, which
is which I think in some way,
it's good to be aware
that like you are capable.
Like we all are capable of hurting people.
- One thing my mom always tells me is,
"You never say never."
And not because you're
putting yourself down.
- Yeah.
- But because you should always be aware
that like people who do
bad stuff are good people.
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying?
- People don't know where
that comes from, man.
Like people end up in a certain
position and they're like,
- Exactly.
- For some reason
you can't just use what
you see in front of you
to determine what this person is.
Some people who do bad things
like it eats them alive.
I think you just have to be
aware that you can do bad things
and that you shouldn't.
You shouldn't wait till
you're in the middle
of doing the bad thing, and you're like,
"Oh, I didn't know I could do that."
- Yeah.
Let me find another question for you.
Ever since I decided that
I wanted to interview you,
I've been really excited
about this question.
- Okay. I'm excited to hear it.
- What's a song lyric, any song lyric,
doesn't have to be yours, could be yours,
that reminds you of someone?
- My brother actually sent
it to me this morning.
Oh, yesterday after I
had the bad interaction
with the executive, he sent it to me.
It's a lot of fake people in,
especially in entertainment industry.
So the line is, so my only goal is
to make a real feel seen,
and I think that resonates with me cause
and my brother, cause we,
we would love uplifting
other artists.
Like, I only wear anytime I have a show,
especially young black artists.
I wear all black brands.
And as I'm doing right now.
- Okay, there you go. You
wanna give him a shout?
- Yeah. It's @bblaccstudios
and it's is just black with
two Bs, two Cs and studios.
Hopefully it'll be somewhere.
I love uplifting people
that I really believe what
in what they do and love what they do.
And then I can love it, like
with them and support them.
And so it hurts when people don't do that.
And then he said, this is
another line that sometimes,
and make a fake to hate life.
Because when you get to that point in,
in that position in your life
where you're really winning,
the same people who are sleeping on you,
they like it's gonna hurt their stomach.
Like it's not gonna sit well.
And it's not a thing of
like wanting to hurt them.
It's just kind of like a
reassurement and reinforcement,
knowing that we're gonna make it.
Something that I wanted to do for myself?
I wanna build my home studio.
A lot of music I have doesn't come out
because I don't have the
immediacy of recording and stuff.
And I used to back in college,
but I lost all my equipment
because of somebody like
who kind of fucked me over.
And I lost a lot of my shit.
So I had to get some equipment.
I still have a bunch of stuff to do.
And I just moved to this apartment.
So like I'm really looking
forward to building
that like studio, in-house
studio, where I can like,
just be creative in that. Like, so yeah.
That's, that's what I wanna do for myself.
- I did wanna ask you something else.
- Oh yeah.
- But let me find my stuff.
Oh. What the hell is this?
- Did somebody leave this?
- Yeah, I think so.
But how's your name on it? That's weird.
Are you sure it's not yours?
I don't know where it
came from. It's so weird.
Oh, is there's a letter too?
Do you wanna read it?
(paper scratches)
- Can you hold that for a
second? I wanna read the letter.
Ahhh...
You want me to read it out?
- If you could. Yeah.
- Gael, as you said,
if the universe presents an opportunity,
the best thing you can do is just take it.
This meeting was the product
of so many subtle opportunities
and delicately place dominoes.
That's all I've been playing
a lot of dominoes lately.
When your action and
inspirations won't charge
your responsibilities.
That's crazy.
You not only remain true to yourself,
but also make others feel
seen and inspire them
with your words.
Honestly, vulnerability and art.
Few words, honesty, vulnerability and art.
Keep creating and following
these inspirations
because the universe uplifts
people who really believe
and love what they do.
Hopefully this $600 help
you stay on your path
and create your home studio
and eventually a beautiful
life with your girl
and a home near your family
and those who fill you with love.
But for now take it one minute at a time.
- Give me a hug.
(muffled talk)
- Like I said, not just for my studio,
but I have like back
issues in my lower back
and I haven't been able to work full time.
So like, it's been, it's
been hard cuz I work retail.
So I stand a lot. Sorry.
Yeah. So the last and I make
good bread too at work too,
which is what sucks. Like
they pay well and stuff,
but I haven't been able to work as much.
The last few checks
have been a little heavy
and I've had to like lean on my girl more.
So trust me that means a
lot. It's gonna help a lot.
Yeah. So thanks.
- Yeah. And I, you don't need to thank me
because like we talked about earlier,
it's all, I feel like it's just teamwork.
- Yeah.
- And...
you don't know how much you've done
for me too seriously.
And I don't, I don't
think you'll ever know.
So I appreciate you as well.
And...
I like, I'm not just saying this.
I think you're so talented
and there is no way
you're not gonna make it.
- Appreciate that.
- Yeah.
You're gonna make me cry too.
- Been kind of hard lately. I don't know.
Like, I'm super hopeful about the future
and I'm embracing the
grind, but sometimes it,
sometimes it's really like tiring.
I'm honestly in a good
place in my life right now.
I don't know if it's obvious,
but it doesn't seem like it,
but I'm in a really good
place in my life right now.
I'm just very grateful.
- I think things are
starting to line up for you.
I think you're all. You're
like, you're just there.
- Yeah. It's been overwhelming.
- Yeah.
Like I didn't, I mean, on my birthday,
I spent a lot of the day crying
because I've been having
a lot of blessings lately
and somehow it's overwhelming
even though like,
I feel like it's been a long time coming,
but a lot of things are
just happening at once.
And I guess I lost faith for a while.
Not, I don't wanna say I
lost faith for a while,
but having faith is
honestly like believing
in things that you can't
necessarily see or touch.
So it's nice to have reminders sometimes.
And I've been getting a
lot of reminders lately,
so it's a nice reminder to stop, you know,
to accept whatever blessings
come my way and not, you know,
feel too overwhelmed to feel
like I don't deserve them.
Or if they're there, I
should just, you know,
really embrace it. So yeah.
I'm done crying. That's enough for today.
Ahhh.
- Thank you so much.
- I can't wait to see you guys.
Talk to any of y'all that
feel like you connect
with my story, so...
- Yeah
- Yeah. Thanks again.
- Yeah.
- Don't get a hug?
- Another hug.
Thank you so much, man.
We're gonna stay connected forever.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah
- Forever.
- Yeah.
- I mean you've been with me forever.
Every, every time, I don't
know if I said this in the,
I think I told you this,
but before every time I perform the song,
I tell the story of where it came from.
- I know. I know.
- So I've been speaking
of you for a while, so.
- Just to make sure that
people find you on Instagram,
let's do like a little challenge.
So I'll have all of you
maybe take a day to yourself
and reflect on how you're feeling,
take a picture or a video
and then use his song
to post it on your story
and tag both of us.
- Yeah.
- So that we could reshare it
and like maybe connect with them.
- That would be, that would be so awesome.
Yeah. And I hope you
guys are all doing well
or if you're not that you're aware of it
and that you're taking care of yourself.
Song is H-Y-R-D question mark.
And we'll see you on Instagram. Yeah?
Yeah.
- Cool. I know you have to go so...
- I voluntarily remove
the microphone this time.
I won. We ended on my terms.
Sorry.
- Yeah, I think you did
have the record for the mic.
- For most drops.